when you were when you signed in 2016
had you already left like uh retail
and you know because i'm assuming you
met with coal in 2012
kept that relationship alive you're
probably dropping music were you
dropping music and working at the same
time or like yeah
and then um
i ended up getting fired from walmart
and i started uh working at the airport
oh that's rough too yeah yeah it is it
was but when i started working at the
airport
and my bread was looking a little
different
like in the in between
2012 and 2016
at a point i was working at the airport
for a minute
and
[Music]
i had a daughter and i was like man [ __ ]
this rap [ __ ] like the money looking
good
this is like a career for me because i
was feeling planes oh yeah i'm like yo
i'm i'm no benefit yeah hell yeah all
kind of benefits so i'm like man [ __ ]
this rap [ __ ] like what i need to rap
for and i got a child on the way i said
pop in the airport too
charlotte airport i mean it's cool i
mean i feel like i have i've had like
seven layovers there you know what's
crazy though like the one thing i loved
about working at the airport is
each day is never the same type [ __ ] you
know you work a regular job like i'm
doing the same [ __ ] every day like every
day was completely different you don't
know what the hell he was going to get
out there